[Music]
all right I have a story here about a
man I was hoping was about a lady yeah
sorry it's about a man yes so he was
suspected of having coronavirus and so
he was put on a ventilator in a hospital
he was isolated he was an ICU I see you
um I thought that [ __ ] in my head but I
didn't wanted to rub oh my god you did
the care unit imagine that's how the
doctor introducing you welcome to the I
see I see you me taking care of you
today guys like the sign oh yeah
so this 40 year old was admitted into
the ICU and then that's when another
patient in that same unit was tested
positive for corona virus so that's why
they ended up isolating this patient as
well and so family members ended up
visiting him at all hospitals looking
into because it's not smoke you're not
supposed to like who the hell approved
of this right so family members visited
and then they hugged and kissed no so
once they arrived they realized that the
hospital turned off the AC in order to
like lessen the probability of like
spreading corona virus cause of heat the
air circulation yeah so they turned off
the AC and so when the family members
visited they brought their own fan no
you're cooler there because they're hot
and they cycle the air and they
circulated the air to everyone oh no no
no it's actually a lot dumber than that
they bought a barbecue pit because they
realized that he was eating shitty
Hospital food they started really
doctors I know
please hear way too much food yeah good
family shitty Hospital great family they
have that tube that like it brings in
the air so they put the tube on the
outside I was shooting out there out the
window and there's like a school part or
a schoolyard right next to me
oh no it's a lot dumber than that it's
good for hospital okay let's keep going
yeah so so okay so they brought in this
air cooler oh they took the mask off the
air and then they put so he has it
directly on his face oh you're getting
close no close-ish in terms of taking
something off oh they were all using the
ventilator just get oxygen because it
gives them a little high no you're going
further away
oh the unplug the ventilator to plug the
AC in oh no yes Fisher is unplugged the
dead guy neck like the clothes of dead
guys in the man time oh my god I mean
who did it is this a family of dumbasses
cuz the hospital to turn it down yeah
the hospital too so dumb uncle that plug
that pull the [ __ ] plug like when
you're in a hospital you don't want to
pull any plug that's when I think it's a
hotel like what oh yeah obviously do
dude I was reading this story me in case
you were like what the [ __ ] and that's
telling that's funny though that's like
you two I'm like people like this are
the worst where they think like I'm just
as smart as a doctor or like the
hospital staff to where I don't need to
ask for permission avoided plug I need
to unplug is I'm just as smart like of
course I'm gonna know this is okay it's
like what's afoot if I was that man I
would pump the [ __ ] out of my family for
the rest of their lives dude so the
thing is here when they
when I am plugged the man's ventilator
it has like hospital equipment they have
like a reserve a battery reserve just in
case for like power outages they use it
to [ __ ] charge their TV you guys
could get pretty stupid that's really
nice but no it had ran for for a half an
hour and that's when the power ran out
and so they alerted the medical staff
who then performed CPR oh Jesus
like I said the man ended up dying the
family's still complained that the guy
cuz I could see that happening to these
machines have like alarms on them yeah I
thought these machines was good what's
this [ __ ] alright you can't unplug it
and it still works machine that's what
they do I know like what what is
happening where is this in India mm-hmm
it is really hot in India I was thinking
like Alabama somewhere no it's happened
in India and so they were saying later
the test results came back and they
confirmed that the man did not have
coronavirus oh my but he did have
difficulty breathing so yeah you needed
the ventilator he did need the venom why
this is so [ __ ] hot figure that out
so misdiagnosed and then Jesus I fled
this family so [ __ ] stupid too like
there was an empty pillow on the chair
and the guy was like Audie to sit down
oh just put on saying that the
temperatures inside the hospital
reportedly hovered around 40 degrees
Celsius which is about a hundred
indoors so maybe they thought that the
AC is just what he needed because it's
too hot
that's the care bro like a TV the see
the hospital is kind of stupid to them
you know what I'm not smart if it's 104
degrees I'm [ __ ] stupid as hell yeah
I'm animal brain I would kill my uncle
for some a/c I opened up the window and
be like man it's a hundred and eight
outside [ __ ] it's worse yeah that when
you stick your hand on your driving the
air is hottest [ __ ] I'll decide to see
I'm not smart room temp - I can't
imagine is that huh yeah that's so
tragic
like but it's funny though you gotta
admit that's just funny as well what was
the reaction of the people I appreciate
they were enjoying the AC for only
thirty minutes oh that was a long road
trip they're probably having a family
day that like uncle George is [ __ ]
sick brand AC is this oh it's so good
they're talking about the AC Wow
reminiscing good it's good to see all
you guys man Coronas is crazy you
discuss this afterwards same again a few
I'll be deny it blame it on my boss why
did the hospital let that happen
I didn't unplug it he unloaded it he
unplugged it didn't plug it right from
the beginning right what if they
unplugged it and saw that the machine
kept going so they're like it's not tied
to that yeah that's why I generator
going for half an hour brown legs that's
less them but I would still be like the
generator be all no no what I just
unplug and like be on a spaceship and
being like I want to put all my hair
dryer like whoa and then the [ __ ]
spaceship breaks yeah in a way and you
know what we could we tend to focus on
the dark side I think it's kind of nice
that his whole family was there when
they pulled the plug and they did it
together yeah they did it all together
what if he [ __ ] hates his family to
it he's just in his [ __ ] ventilator
like you [ __ ] idiot
you're like don't worry uncle we're here
now I wonder how outdated their
equipment is - because I know in America
like you know the theme that scans like
your vitals the one that's like on your
finger if it falls off for even like
five minutes the things start screaming
and a nurse is gonna come should the
generator be like screaming there's a
European stereotype about Americans in
our health care in the hospital they
think everything here is like [ __ ] up
like it [ __ ] up in a sense where it's
it's it's like super low quality and
it's like all shitty and all [ __ ] yeah
we have the best though I mean our
middle our staff has a stereotype that I
heard that's crazy
Europeans this is a joke running joke of
how like our hospitals and all this [ __ ]
is all [ __ ] up so they don't want to
get sick you're going to our hospitals
or anything expensive wise yeah with
that butter health care but equipment
cleanliness wise well let's [ __ ] yeah
dude I was in Costa Rica in a hospital
bro [ __ ] that you might go just be out
of motel I was those spiders in the room
there was cobwebs everywhere it was
[ __ ] crazy the doctor's stethoscope
song rusty and [ __ ] well he had a surfer
doctor that was weird right she was
really cool but but she was the bright
spot in this thing the nurse lady doctor
was dope she's like a nurse lady doctor
well she was a female doctor circle or
nurse okay no but it was very you know I
wished I was here the whole time was
there air conditioning
yeah no no I don't remember the man it
was very hot for me so maybe there was
did Nikki try anything
Nikki's like it's too hot where's the
a/c I got your back dude I told my dad
that when the first time I had kidney
stones in like 2007 I told my dad I
wanted to die as I pull the plug cuz I
was hooked up to something and he was
like there's nothing to plug son
gotta [ __ ] deal with this not on a
respirator but I really did say that it
sounds like a joke I really did say that
because it was in so much pain I thought
when like in December when I have the
freaking which i think is oh no no no
yeah I think so why are you afraid of it
you would think you had it what I mean
afraid of it the Rhoda are you so afraid
of getting it you not get it again okay
that's not confirmed that she got it yes
well first of all it's mainly about it's
easy to get the thing no I'm not worried
about me so much I'm worried about
people around me this is like Casey you
know I have a kid I mean but are the
kids like don't you get the antibody can
you be still a carrier they'll get I
mean if you still get it but the the
chances are even way lower than like I
thought if you contracted it right you
get the antibody like can you can you
still be a carrier you have the antibody
you cannot be there that's what I was
leaking do you have the antibody so if
you think you had it in December you
could test if you have the antibody and
if you do then you don't have to worry
anymore yeah get tested I just [ __ ] that
no after that he's a different version
there's a different one that we saw yeah
they'll be your swab and in and does the
antibody one right it was coded our
doctor neighbor was saying the prop so
that technically because every virus has
its own code so the minute your body
responds to the virus and creates the
antibody for it you cannot catch that
virus again what they're saying about
how people are able to catch it again
it's not that they're they're catching
again it's the test for the antibodies
isn't that accurate because the kovat
virus leaves a very simple it's a very
similar like like blueprint to the
common cold which is why and we they
haven't developed one that can
accurately test antibodies the antibody
a hundred percent so that's why when
they test it it's oh yeah you do have
the antibody but there's still a chance
I don't know like 30 percent chance that
it's you just have to have my body
through a common cold that's what the
thing is
geez it's not cold in 19 as cold fit 17
could be here socially I'm gonna get
tested because I'm gonna go to Jersey in
a couple weeks and I feel that in order
to give everybody a peace of mind as
soon as I get back I should take a
letting you guys know and I heard that
it's easy cuz one of my friends she does
it every almost every week now right
because she's her line of work she's
constantly out there doing it um and
then so just how long does it take to
get results 48 hours yeah it's it's a
legit one it's not like a Mickey Mouse
one so that's tight what what are you
doing in Jersey oh I'm gonna go visit my
partner my business partner and it's on
his farm that's it yep nothing else
that's all okay yeah well
[Music]
[Music]